Hallo, meine Name ist Gül Tokös, ich bin hier als Assistent, als Tätig.
Ich bin für Sie heute zuständig.
Was? Aber ich muss zuerst Ihre persönliche Daten fragen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Nur, dass Sie meinen Namen und so etwas wissen müssen, ist ja klar.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Tim Schröder.
Tim Schröder. Herr Schröder, oder?
Genau.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schröder?
Ich bin 66, ich bin 58.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Wir haben zwölf und dritten 66.
Okay.
Zwölf und dritten?
Zwölf und dritten, zwölf und mehr?
Okay, okay.
1966 geboren.
Okay, danke.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Halb, halb, halb.
Ich bin 182, war ich zumindest immer.
Und ich wiege so um die 70 kg.
70 kg.
Okay, gut.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, also, was ich nicht vertragen habe, ich habe mal Paracetamol genommen
und habe so einen jungen Ausschlag bekommen.
Das soll ich also nicht mehr nehmen.
Haben Sie die Lebensmittelunvertraglichkeit?
Nein, ich kann nicht alles vertragen.
Langtourist oder Milch oder keine?
Nein, nein, eigentlich habe ich da nichts.
Super, super. Was ist denn von Beru?
Ich bin Lehrer.
Lehrer.
Haben Sie Stress in der Arbeit?
Ja, natürlich habe ich Stress in der Arbeit.
Also als Lehrer, das ist super anstrengend.
Sie haben immer ständig Lärm.
Sie haben ständig neue Anforderungen.
Die Kinder sind nicht mehr so, wie sie früher waren.
Also, doch, also bei der Arbeit haben wir wirklich viel Stress.
Ja, Sie sind verweigert?
Ja, ja, ja.
Wie ist die Kinder mit dem Haus?
Ja, ja, die Kinder sind schon aus dem Haus, aber ich wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Ja, ja.
Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind schon Erwachsenen.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei.
Okay, Herr Schruder, was für die Zutun?
Was kann ich für die Zutun?
Ja, also ich mache mir so ein bisschen Sorgen.
Ich habe ordentliche Bauchschmerzen, die auch gar nicht richtig besser werden.
Und zwar, ja, das ist jetzt eigentlich schon längere Zeit,
dass ich immer mal in Wechsel, mal habe ich das Gefühl,
ich kann überhaupt nicht auf die Toilette gehen.
Ich habe tagelang keinen Stuhlgang.
Und dann wiederum habe ich Tage, wo ich fünfmal am Tag Durchfall habe
und wo das nur so rausschießt.
Und ich habe also ordentlich Bauchschmerzen,
die so, so ja um den Bauchnabel rum, würde ich sagen,
sind diese Schmerzen.
Und ganz schlimm sind die in dem Augenblick,
wo ich auf die Toilette muss.
Wenn ich also Stuhlgang habe, dann habe ich das Gefühl,
die Schmerzen sind wirklich noch schlimmer.
Okay, zeig es mir bitte, wo Ihre Schmerzen sind.
Die sind also um den Bauchnabel herum.
Ja, ich höre nicht.
Rund herum.
Also nicht.
Ich habe nicht gehört, ich habe nicht gehört,
bitte da heran.
Ich habe nicht gehört, meine Farbe ist weg.
Um den Bauchnabel herum.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Na, das ist noch nicht so lange jetzt.
Vielleicht so zwei, drei Wochen?
Zwei, drei Wochen.
Wegen diese Schmerzen, können Sie vielleicht
Ihre Hausarzt besuchen oder nicht?
Ja, also ich bin hier nicht extra dahin gegangen,
weil ich gedacht habe, naja gut,
man kann ja mal ein bisschen Bauch haben,
aber jetzt habe ich das so gemerkt,
dass ich mich eben auch richtig schlecht fühle,
dass ich manchmal nicht so gut Luft bekomme,
dass ich nachts nicht gut schlafe.
Und ja, ich habe eigentlich auch nicht so richtig Appetit,
habe denn jetzt auch tatsächlich ein bisschen Gewicht verloren.
Wie viel Kilo habe Sie abgenommen?
Ja, sonst habe ich immer 73 Kilo geworden,
jetzt wiege ich nur noch 70?
73, drei Kilo habe ich abgenommen, ja.
Aber seit wann?
Na ja, vielleicht in zwei Monaten?
Zwei Monaten.
Sie haben zwei, drei Wochen, die sich schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen sind jetzt noch nicht so lange da,
aber dass ich mich so ein bisschen mehr eingeschränkt fühle,
das ist schon länger.
Warum können Sie zu uns kommen, die Schmerzen?
Weil die Schmerzen stärker geworden sind, ja.
Wie viele Stunden?
Heute oder gestern, seit wann?
Na ja, das ist jetzt jeden Tag ein bisschen schlimmer geworden.
Das ist, ja.
Okay.
Wann haben Sie sich letzte Stuhlgang gemacht?
Ja, heute Morgen.
Heute Morgen.
Ich habe auch wieder solche Schmerzen dann auf der Toilette.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nee, direkt übel ist mir nicht.
Ich habe nur nicht so guten Appetit.
Also es ist nicht so, dass ich mich übergeben muss oder so.
Dass mir schlecht ist, so wie See krank oder so.
Nee, das nicht, aber ich schmecken mir halt nicht.
Nein, haben Sie auch nicht erbrochen, oder?
Nein, nein, übergeben musste ich mir nicht.
Nein, okay, gut.
Wie ist Ihre Übrung?
Übring.
Was ist mit meinem Urin heute?
Alles normal, habe ich keine Beschwerden?
Ja, habe Sie keine Probleme, Stuhlgang oder Übring.
Gut.
Also ich habe sowieso schon seit mehreren Jahren immer wieder Hämorrhien.
Deswegen habe ich immer mal wieder so Blut auf dem Stuhlgang drauf.
Und da ist schon mehrfach, sind da so Bandligaturen gemacht worden.
Das letzte war vor zwei Monaten.
Und dadurch kenne ich, dass das eigentlich immer mal so ein bisschen Blut auch im Stuhlgang ist.
Das ist bei mir eigentlich normal.
Ja, wegen der meiner Internetverschlechter, deswegen nicht so gut verstehen.
Sie haben schon gesehen, ihren Stuhlblut.
Ja, weil ich Hämorrhiden habe regelmäßig.
Hämorrhiden.
Seit einigen Jahren.
Aber wegen Hämorrhids wurden sie operiert.
Ja, da wurde ich schon mehrfach operiert, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie operiert, wurden?
Also ich habe diese Geschichte seit vier Jahren.
Und jetzt die letzte Operatur, also diese letzte Bandligatur war vor zwei Monaten.
Oh, zwei Monaten.
Haben Sie wegen dieser Schmerzenkoloskopie?
Noch nicht, jetzt in letzter Zeit lang.
Vor Jahren ist mal eine gemacht worden.
Und dann hat man festgestellt vor vier Jahren, dass da diese Hämorrhiden sind.
Und dann hat man die halt behandelt.
Aber eine erneute Koloskopie ist dann nicht gemacht worden.
Und wie ist das mit der
Verkaufung?
Die andere Körperteile aus?
Nein, das ist eigentlich auf den Bauch beschränkt.
Nein, das strahlt nirgendwo hin aus.
Keine Rechte unter Bauch.
Nein, das strahlt nicht aus, würde ich nicht sagen.
Das ist so um den Bauchnabel rum, aber da heftig.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht fieberig.
Manchmal schläft sich in der Nacht.
Das schon, dann denke ich ja, könnte schon sein, dass ich mal Fieber habe.
Aber so jetzt, ich glaube nicht, dass ich Temperatur habe.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Ja, sagst dich gerade ja.
Seit wann haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Ach ja, immer mal wieder, vielleicht so in den letzten 2 Monaten oder so.
2 Monate, okay.
Haben Sie für Erkrankungen, für chronische Erkrankungen,
beispielsweise Artilie, Hypertony, Brutzuka?
Ja, also ein bisschen, in meinem Alter hat man natürlich ein bisschen Bluthochdruck.
Ja, klar.
Also das habe ich jetzt schon.
Bitte?
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Ja, das hat man so vor 10 Jahren festgestellt, da war es auch kein Wunder,
weil der Beruf, da hat man ja auch immer Stress
und da kann der Blutdruck schon mal hochgehen.
Dann nehme ich aber Tabletten, dann nehme ich morgens Walzatan.
Walzatan, wie viel Migran, wie viel Dosierung?
Ich weiß nicht, was da draufsteht.
Wenn ich jetzt gerade überfragt, müsste ich nachgucken, was auf der Schachtel steht.
Und dann habe ich so ein bisschen, so ein saures Ausstoßen, so ein Reflugs,
insbesondere wenn ich abends spät noch etwas gegessen habe
oder auch wenn ich etwas Süßes gegessen habe,
dann habe ich schon so Probleme, dass ich so sauer aufstoßen muss.
Und dann nehme ich halt bei Bedarf Omeprazol.
Okay, Omeprazol.
Omeprazol, wie viel Migran, wie viel Dosierung?
Also ich nehme die ja nur nach Bedarf, aber wie viel da drin ist, weiß ich nicht.
Okay, bei Bedarf, muss ich.
Okay.
Die Wichter sind diese Bauchschmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala
von 0 bis 10, wobei nur den Keine schmerzen.
Aber 10 ist sehr stark schmerzen, wenn man die Antifräschen.
Die stark sind die Schmerzen.
Also wenn so eine Kohle gerade so richtig im Gange ist,
dann würde ich sagen, ist das schon über der Hälfte.
Also bei 6 sind die Schmerzen bestimmt, ja.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder jetzt gerade?
Nein, also das sind ja so kohlikartige Schmerzen.
Zwischen durch die, das war ein bisschen zurück,
aber dann krampft es sich eben immer mehr wieder zusammen.
Gibt es etwas, da diese Schmerzen auslösen?
Ja, ich sagte ja, wenn ich auf die Toilette gehe, dann wird es besonders schlimm.
Beim Stuhlgang.
Nein, beim Stuhlgang, wunder.
Aber warum?
Wegen Verstoffen?
Also dann tut es mir jedenfalls mehr weh.
Also wenn ich so einen Durchfalltag habe,
dann habe ich schon Angst davor auf die Toilette zu gehen,
weil ich weiß, gleich tut es wieder weh.
Okay, haben Sie, gibt es etwas, was diese Schmerzen liegen?
Ja, also ich glaube, so ganz schlimm ist es nicht,
wenn ich in Ruhe bin, wenn ich in Bett liege
und eine bequeme Position habe, so ein bisschen in Seitenlage,
dann fühle ich mich eigentlich noch am besten, ja.
Aber man kann ja nicht den ganzen Tag nur in Bett liegen.
Ja, seit wann haben Sie in so einem Schlafstörende?
Ach, ja, so Einschlafprobleme habe ich eigentlich schon länger,
je nachdem, auch wie es so bei der Arbeit ist,
wenn da besonders viel Stress ist.
Aber wegen dieser Schmerzen vielleicht?
Ja, aber ich würde sagen,
das ist schon länger, dass ich nicht gut einschlage.
Okay, verstehe.
Mit Ihrer Familie, mit der Kleider haben Sie diese Schmerzen
und Ihre Frau gibt es auch Bauchschmerzen?
Meine Frau hat dann keine Bauchschmerzen, nein.
Sie immer zu Hause ihre Essen.
Ob ich immer zu Hause esse?
Gestern, zum Beispiel.
Ja, also ich esse natürlich normalerweise zu Hause
und wenn ich einen langen Arbeitstag in der Schule habe,
nehme ich mir etwas mit und dann essen wir abends zu Hause zusammen.
Ja, haben Sie Bullzucker oder die andere Stoffwechselerkrankungen?
Nein, Zuckerkampf bin ich nicht, nein, nein.
Okay, gut.
Sie haben Beisartan und Omeprol eingenommen.
Und haben Sie die andere Medikamente regelmäßig dabei,
wenn Sie es eingenommen?
Ich nehme noch, wenn ich Schmerzen in den Kniegelenken habe,
dann nehme ich mal Ibuprofen ein.
Ja, manchmal habe ich mal...
Was ist das Problem Ihrer Knie?
Ja, ich habe dahin und wieder mal Schmerzen,
wenn ich ein bisschen Sport gemacht habe
oder wenn ich viel Fahrrad gefahren bin,
dann zum Beispiel die Kniegelenke ein bisschen weh
und dann nehme ich halt eine Schmerztablette.
Nehmen Sie die Schmerztablette bei Bedarf, aber?
Nur bei Bedarf, ja.
Okay.
Rachen Sie Herr Schirruder?
Rachen Sie.
Ja, leider ja.
Seit wann?
Ich auch sogar ziemlich stark, ja.
Seit wann rachen Sie?
Bitte?
Ja, ich habe erst so mein Wachsendenalter angefangen,
so mit etwas über 30, ja, so 20 Jahre.
Wie viele war? Wie viele?
Wie viele Zigaretten? Darf ich gar nicht sagen.
Das sind, meine ich, mal schon 2 Päckchen am Tag, ja.
Oh, 2 Päckchen.
Haben Sie schon versucht, mit dem Rachen aufgehört?
Ja, aber machen Sie das mal neben dem Schulbetrieb und so, ne?
Ich meine, in der Schule darf man jetzt nicht mehr rauchen,
aber dann muss ich halt morgens, bevor ich zur Arbeit gehe
und dann rauche ich halt nachmittags, wenn ich hefte, korrigiere.
Okay, aber es ist ein Krieg.
Für die Herzkrankheit und Lungen gibt es viele wegen dieser Rauchen.
Wenn Sie denken, mit dem Rachen aufgehört,
wir können ihr aufzuhören, wir können Ihnen gerne helfen.
Ja, es würde viel Geld sparen, ja, es würde viel Geld sparen,
wenn ich nicht mehr so viel rauchen würde, ja.
Zimt Ihnen sie Alkohol?
Naja, also ich trinke schon abends gerne ein Glas Rotwein, ja.
Jede Abend?
Ja, so gut wie jeden Abend, ja.
Seit wann?
Seit ich erwachsen bin, also, ja.
Früher habe ich auch mal mehr getrunken,
aber jetzt, in den letzten Jahren,
habe ich ein Glas Rein am Abend gemäßigt, ja.
Okay, fühlen Sie sich manchmal Yukreis?
Yukreis habe ich nicht, ne?
Ja, haben Sie Ihre Augenpartneränderungen bemerkt?
Farbveränderung?
Ja, gelb nicht, beispielsweise.
Nee, nee, gelbe Augen habe ich nicht, nee, nee.
Ja, okay, gut.
Leben, ihre Eltern noch, ihre Vater, ihre Mutter, ja Vater.
Meine Eltern leben beide noch, sind beide hoch betagt, ja.
Sind ihre Eltern chronische Erkrankungen?
Also, wahrscheinlich haben die auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck,
was alle Leute haben, vielleicht haben die auch ein bisschen Diabetes,
weiß ich aber gar nicht so genau.
Irgendwann haben die mal erzählt,
dass mein Vater bei so einer Kondyskopie,
dass man da Darmpoliten rausgemacht hat,
aber sonst weiß ich da eigentlich nicht,
dass die irgendwie besonders krank wären.
Nein, nein, eigentlich ist sie erstaunlich,
ist sie erstaunlich für ihre Alter.
Können Sie bitte wiederhauen? Ich höre ihn nicht.
Ihre Vater-Koloskopie, wie Kind,
da hat man Polypen festgestellt im Darm
und hat die eben entfernt.
Und die Art ist gutartig, oder?
Ja, ja, die sind befundet worden
und die waren nicht auffällig.
Ja, haben Ihre Eltern auch chronische Bauchschmerzen,
Durpfall?
Davon haben die mir bisher nie erzählt
und auch aus meiner Kinderzeit kann ich das nicht erinnern, nein.
Nein, ich habe mich manchmal weg.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister habe ich nicht, nein.
Sie sind sehr ein Einzelkind.
Okay, ähm...
Können Sie...
Möchten Sie etwas hinfügen?
Ja, ich habe Ihnen jetzt so viel erzählt,
lassen Sie mich überlegen.
Also, ich habe halt diese Bauchschmerzen,
die immer schlimmer werden
und diese, ja, auch, dass ich mich so schwach fühle
und dass ich auch so gar nicht mehr leistungsfähig bin.
Ja, also, wenn Fahrradfahren,
kann ich nicht mehr in hohen Gang schalten
und, ähm, was weiß ich,
bei der Treppe muss ich mich anstrengen,
hochzukommen, ja, in der Schule.
Wann war Ihre letzte Blutdruck?
Bitte, was? Wann? Letzte?
Blutdruck.
Wie der letzte Blutdruck war?
Der war so bei 135 zu 80.
Ich messe immer mal wieder so,
zweimal in der Woche morgens.
Super, super.
Ja, ähm, ich bin fertig.
Bitte?
Ja, vielen Dank für die ausführliche Erklärung.
Ja, ich bin gerade fertig.
Ich denke für Sie nicht so schwer,
nicht schlimmer Krankheit,
aber ich muss etwas süß,
körperliche,
gerne Ihnen körperliche untersuchen.
Sie möchten mich körperlich untersuchen?
Ja, ja.
Danach werde ich ein bisschen,
werde ich ein bisschen Blut abnehmen
und EKG schreiben.
Ähm,
gönnchen Sie ein,
kein Problem, oder?
Nein, nein, ich habe jetzt ja Zeit, ja, ja.
Okay, okay.
Danke.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Herr Schuröde,
haben Sie etwas bemerkt,
Ihre Stuhlkangveränderung,
sowie Bleistiftstuhl
und wie sieht aus Ihrer Durchfälle?
Hm, also Bleistiftstuhl ist mir nicht aufgefallen
und die Durchfälle sind,
ja, übel riechend,
wie so Durchfälle sind,
mit Speiserästen
und ziemlich wässrig.
Wässrig, okay, danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja?
Also Herr Schurde,
am Anfang haben Sie gesagt,
dass Sie mehrere Jahren,
dass Sie sich mehrere Jahren unangenehm gefühlt hat.
mehrere Jahre nicht?
Schon länger.
Schon länger, okay.
Schon länger habe ich gesagt, ja, also einige Wochen.
Ja?
Also, hatten Sie manchmal Durchfälle
und hatten Sie manchmal
Verstopfungen?
Das habe ich mich erzählt, genau.
Das habe ich richtig verstanden.
Das haben Sie richtig verstanden, ja.
Okay, also es war,
also seit zwei Monaten
haben Sie manchmal Durchfälle,
haben Sie manchmal Durchfälle.
Ja, aber vielleicht auch ein bisschen länger schon,
aber schon längere Zeit,
vielleicht schon auch drei Monate,
aber bis mir das jetzt aufgefallen ist, ja.
Jetzt ist es halt alles schlechter geworden, ne?
Deswegen bin ich jetzt endlich zum Arzt gegangen.
Okay, waren Sie schon mal
im Hausatz oder nicht?
Wegen dieser Sache jetzt nicht, nein.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden?
Drogen.
Ob ich Drogen konsumiere, nein,
nein, das habe ich bei meinen Schülern genug,
da ich selber konsumiere, keine Drogen, nein.
Haben Sie Brustchema und Bemarkt?
Brustschmerzen.
Ne, Brustschmerzen, das Einzige, was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass ich halt so, ja, schnell außer Puste bin, ne?
Was Sie gesagt haben, ich kann nicht mehr im Hohengang Fahrrad fahren
und bei der Treppe bin ich schnell außer Puste
und da merke ich, dass ich so nicht mehr so belastbar bin.
Aber Brustschmerzen im eigentlichen Sinne,
so wie dass sich da irgendwas zusammenkrammst oder so,
nee, das habe ich nicht.
Seit wann war ihr da, heißt es Knoppen?
Mein Herz klopft hoffentlich schon seit ich lebe, ja.
Also nochmal, wie war Ihre Frage?
Seit wann?
Ihre Stimmung hat sich nicht gut an.
Ich habe die Frage noch nicht verstehen können.
Ich habe eine Probleme mit Internet.
Wir haben einige heute, ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Alles gut.
Hab eine Frage?
Ja.
Fühlen Sie sich nach dem Stuhlgang nicht vollständig entleert?
Ja, gerade an den Durchfalltagen habe ich das Gefühl,
dass da irgendwie immer noch was kommt, ja.
Da muss man ja auch nach ein paar Minuten dann oft mal schon wieder los, ja.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Keine Frage.
Eine Frage, wie ernähren Sie sich?
Meine Frau kocht, ja.
Und sie kocht eigentlich, würde ich das schon als gesunde Mischkost ansehen, ja.
Mit, also viel Gemüse, viel Obst, Fleisch in Maßen,
viel Vollkornbrot, hin und wieder auch mal Kuchen und so Süßspeisen,
aber jetzt nicht übermäßig.
Danke.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Die zwei Team, her Team.
Ihr Name können Sie beschäftigen.
Erste, der Ende.
T-I-M.
Und seid ihr im Status gefragt, oder?
Im Status wurde noch nicht gefragt, aber ich bin natürlich als Lehrer gegen Corona geimpft.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestellt, Frau Gerhard.
Können wir erst als Gezüchter anfangen?
Ja, hallo, aber Sie sind Frau der Herr.
Frau Berestin.
Ja, ich höre nicht.
Als Oberärztin kann ich ja wohl eine Frau sein, ja.
Als Patient muss ich immer das Geschlecht annehmen, was ich gerade hier so auf dem Zettel habe.
Manchmal hat es ja auch relevant, ob es jetzt Mann oder Frau ist.
Frau Berestin?
Aber ich bin jetzt natürlich als Ihr Ansprechpartner eine Frau.
Okay.
Hallo Frau Berestin.
Schönen guten Tag.
Sie haben Sie einen Moment Zeit für mich.
Ja, natürlich.
Wie lange sind Sie hier?
Wir haben eine neue Patiente.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen diese Patiente vorstellen, darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Der Patiente heißt Tim Schruder.
Er ist 56 Jahre alt und am 12.
Südte 1966 geboren.
Er ist 180 kg und 70 kg.
Er ist lege, er habe viel Stress im Arbeitsplatz.
Er ist heiratet.
Er wohnt mit seinem Frau zusammen.
Er ist ein Paar-Sethomol-Alarg.
Er klagt über auch in Appetence.
Er sagte, dass er zwei Monate drei kg abgenommen hat.
Er beschreibt, dass er zwei Monate drei kg abgenommen hat.
Er beschreibt, dass er sagt, dass er die Paragraph-Region lokalisiert hat.
Er klagt über auch Hemorrhids, aber schon lange haben er wurde wegen Hemorrhids operiert.
Er habe Artillery-Hypertony seit 10 Jahren.
Er klagt über auch die Paragraph-Region.
Ein bisschen Zeit haben wir ja noch?
Ja.